Oh
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and,
Huh?
Just checking in on you.
Sorry Cleo.
My dog just popped up like what the fuck dude?
What's going on everybody?
How are Ya?
How's it going?
Do you guys watch any sports lately?
Go Jays,
baseball there.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
What a difference.
A couple of fucking days makes my god the fucking Cleveland Indians up three
games to one looking to end their streak.
Do,
did I call it or did I fucking call it?
Ah,
what did I say?
Did I say it to you guys?
I thought I said that.
This is just fitting.
They say that on Monday cause I think it was three games to two by then I said
that whatever team was going to fucking win was going to look like they were
going to lose.
So they taught you the shit out of their fans or whatever team was going to
lose,
was going to look like they were gonna win.
Cause they'd take their emotions right through the fucking stratosphere and then
slam 'em right down on the pavement and gain seven was literally the microcosm
that Delta,
what they'll weigh.
That whole fucking game played out was basically,
if you ever wanted to know what it was like to be a Chicago cub or a Cleveland
Indian fan and the only reason why they both didn't face plan each other is
because mathematically it was not an option.
Somebody had to win the fucking thing,
but neither team was just get,
neither team was just going to win this fucking series.
That was basically it.
That was the point I was trying to make the other day.
They were going to torture the fuck out of their fans to the point that even if
they did win the thing,
he'd still have some sort of nervous fucking twitch or a tick for like three
days afterwards.
Jesus Christ.
What a game.
If you didn't watch game seven,
I feel bad for you as a fucking human being,
you know,
as it's fucking 71 degrees in Cleveland,
Ohio in November,
that no reason to be concerned.
Let's play it off.
Oh,
Jesus.
Okay.
Enjoy it.
Enjoy.
While last people,
before we get to the tipping point where this global warming thing isn't a fun
thing in November anymore.
Anyways,
back to bread and circus.
Let's talk a little baseball here.
Dot.
The base fault.
Um,
congratulations.
Two,
2016 world series champions.
The fucking Chicago.
I never thought I'd died.
Yeah,
I didn't.
I mean,
I guess I thought I'd say that at some point when it finally saw the red sox
winning.
Congratulations to the cubs fans.
I've been there,
you know,
and I only,
I only last,
you know,
out of the 86 years,
I only saw 36 years of it.
Right?
Of course,
you know,
whatever the first 10,
you're just a kid running around fucking sticking shit.
It fucking,
you know,
you're poking dead skunks and stuff.
You don't give a fuck about a curse.
Right.
Some for my teen years on,
I,
I've suffered 20 fucking years.
If I'm honest.
Uh,
I vaguely remember 78 and know 86 was my,
was my christening as a red sox fan.
Like,
hey bill,
this is what it's going to be like.
Buckle up.
Right?
So I've been there and Cleveland Indian fans,
my condolences.
I been there too.
I've fucking been there too.
But what a fucking game that was Jesus Christ.
And you knew what?
The cubs had to go out early.
They had a score,
a bunch of fucking rungs because as the game went on,
it was going to tip in favor of the Indians because they had,
they had fresh or arms and everybody was fucking shitting on all fucking,
uh,
the guy from the devil rays.
I don't know anybody's names,
by the way.
I don't know anybody's name.
So just fucking deal with it.
And they were all shitting on him for putting Chapman in there.
I'm on the depth chart now so I can look at the face and know who the fuck I'm
talking about.
Right for keep putting Chapter Julian.
It's like,
dude,
they've played three elimination games in a row.
You got to use the guy.
Don't you think he brought a middle to early?
I love when people say that they haven't even coached a little league fucking
team to a victory yet.
And they're questioning what a major league,
I mean I guess she can question it but,
and it's always like,
well the guy who I would have put in who didn't go in and see,
you have no idea what would happen would have happened if you put him in.
I'm going to hypothetically say that we then would have won the fucking game or
already gone smoother.
So I look smarter.
They had to put that guy in there and um,
what was,
what was the big problem you put the fucking guy in instead of throwing 105 he
was throwing 98 I mean,
well what are you gonna do?
You had to do it.
Cubs go up.
I can't remember what the fuck happened.
There was so many goddamn twists and turns.
What was it?
It was like five to one
then like a wild pitch or whatever and fucking lie ahead.
Cheese.
You want to see the funniest fucking,
if you want to see the funniest,
like,
like run a tweets.
Go look at Jason Law heads,
Twitter,
that fucking guy,
he quit in the fifth inning.
You know I was just going to wait to the pitchers and catchers report,
right?
And then fucking two seconds later,
wild pitch.
It's five to fucking tree.
It's still a game.
Oh,
I never saw a guy.
He just what?
He was packing it in,
packing it in packing it in.
Um,
and you said he wasn't going to tweet anymore until the catcher's pitcher's
reported and then all of a sudden they fucking tie it up.
That home run.
Who the fuck can I got to get his name right though?
It's Cleveland step stepchild.
Davis,
right?
Was that oh it was the left fielder.
Holy Shit.
I gotta tell you something right now.
I flip flopped so many times.
Who the fuck I wanted to see when I initially I was with Cleveland cause
everybody wanted the cubs fans.
I saw that 30 for 30 with Bartman and I was just like,
you know,
at these guys did not the fucking salt of the earth people that they try to make
them out to be the happy go lucky,
take his shirt off.
Maybe we win,
maybe we lose.
As long as we enjoy the America's pastime,
these aren't who these are.
They're just like me.
Every red sox,
every Yankees,
that'd be Philly Fan.
I actually argued with the,
a Yankee fan today was going like,
fuck the cubs that Steve Bartman Shit.
They ruined that kid's life.
That wouldn't have happened in New York.
I was like,
get the fuck out of,
you know when that happened in New York,
what happened in New York,
it would have happened in Boston.
But you know what,
in fairness to cubs fan base,
what that really was was the morning,
you know,
the shock jock guys.
And what they did was they stirred up the lower 10% 15% of people,
you know,
it was pissed as I would be or whatever.
There's no fucking way what you really get on a phone and start making depth,
death threats.
I mean really think about the level of mouth breathing more on that you would
have to be to take it to that level.
Um,
so I don't,
so whatever.
So initially that's kind of,
I was,
I'm a contrary and everyone's for the cubs.
So I was rooting for the fucking Indians.
And then what happens?
They went up three games to one and I'm texting with a couple of my Indian
buddies and one of them is a cheat.
She's just so fucking like,
we know when they were winning a game four and it was like,
you know,
I don't know nine to something.
And he was going through it.
I,
I hope,
I hope it goes all the way up to like fucking,
I always go 19 runs.
I hope they run out of pitchers.
And immediately I was thinking like,
Jesus Christ,
how quickly the suffering forget.
Why would you wish that on them?
You just want to win.
Right?
And then he was going like,
now we've got Lebron.
This is just the beginning.
We're going to go on a run,
like they were going to stick and somebody tweeted or texted Cleveland title
town after two fucking titles.
You don't even have a fucking hockey team.
And you end up in the Brown and study.
You lost your fucking team.
You know,
the city treated him so shitty.
They thought Baltimore was a better fucking option.
All right,
you're far from fucking.
So then they started bugging me.
I'm just a contrarion cunt.
I didn't have a dog in the fight and I was happy that one fee.
It'd be honest with you.
I was happy for Cleveland or Chicago that went teams.
Uh,
misery was going to end,
right.
So at that point then I was like,
well,
fuck this.
I'm going to root for the cubs.
Right.
I've got a couple of relatives that cubs fans and I got to say,
I'm fucking,
you know,
I'll,
I'll go to shit.
Then I was kind of like,
yeah,
but I like the Indians Fan.
I like,
I like Cleveland,
you know,
Cleveland needs a fucking hand dude,
that downtown area.
It's gradually coming back.
Every time I come there,
it looks better.
I love the Midwest.
Well Chicago's Midwest too,
but I don't know,
that's kind of so like the New York City of the Midwest,
um,
tremendously underrated city still.
But anyways,
so it's still kind of hanging in there for them.
And uh,
you know what the final tipping point was when Mike Friends Saska trashed the
fucking cubs for showing Bill Murray Goldman Udl,
sue her,
you know,
the whole dual Marijo Durfee talk thing.
You know,
it didn't work for me.
Mike Francesca,
who gives a fuck what works for you and what does it,
your team's not in the playoff.
All right,
you're a nonfactor.
Your team's a nonfactor.
It the funniest fucking thing,
man.
I Yankee fans,
they cannot handle the fact that other people are winning championships and a
good fucking time.
And it's sort of the unwritten rule because whenever the Yankees won a world
series,
which God knows is quite a bit like ESPN there,
their stock line is,
they'll go in all is right in the baseball world again.
It's like,
aren't you guys supposed to pretend that you're kind of rooting for any,
you're not really rooting for anybody.
Um,
so anyways,
fuck Mike Francesco,
Francesco.
He's one of those fucking guys who doesn't realize that he's just as stupid as I
am.
He's one of those guys where he's just been doing it so fucking long that he
really,
he forgets that he's just commenting on shit.
That doesn't matter dude.
You're talking about a baseball game.
Okay.
All the shit that has happened even in New York,
fucking New York City,
all this shit that's fucking happened there.
The cataclysmic world events that have happened there and the level of
seriousness that that guy takes himself.
Oh,
with his stethoscope,
fucking headphones.
That guy,
he drives me up the fuck.
I haven't never been more happy that for fucking mad dog when he got the fuck
out of there.
Jesus Christ to be looking across from that pompous ass.
Is there anything worse than the box seats fucking sports fan that is just so
fucking impressed with themselves and their dumb sweaters and shit?
I Dunno.
You give them a little more fancy as seat,
and I'm telling you it's,
it's like the space shuttle for their ego and they just go right up over here.
The daffy duck thing didn't work for me.
Oh God.
Well maybe,
maybe the cubs out of fucking,
you know,
rethink their relationship with Bill Murray.
Hey Mike,
are you the fucking Bill Murray of,
of,
of sports broadcasters fucking Jack off.
He's just another guy who watches sports and never gets on a treadmill.
I don't understand.
How can you look at all those guys in that level of shape?
And when you're at the end of the game,
when you go into brush your teeth,
you don't look at yourself like Jesus Christ.
Can I at least need a fucking salad?
Every once in a while?
Oh,
this feels right.
This feels great to totally overreact to what he said.
It's a fun thing.
So anyways,
um,
congratulations to the Chicago cubs.
You got the fucking goat off your back.
Whatever the fuck you want to call it was the dumbest curse ever.
Okay?
You can't bring livestock to a baseball game.
All right?
You know,
what she really did is you did not have a curse the same way the red sox didn't
have a curse.
What it really was was you were fans of an unbelievably inept franchise for a
long fucking time.
And uh,
thank God,
you know,
we finally got Theo Epstein,
we finally got Terry Francona,
we finally got the ownership that the red sox have and it all came together and
we finally did what teams like the fucking Yankees,
the cardinals,
the Patriots,
teams like that,
that know how to fucking win.
I actually can't say the Patriots.
That's even modern modern era.
The Celtics back in the day,
um,
you know,
as much as I hate the fucking Yankees like that,
their,
their front office,
their ownership,
their franchise,
their farm system,
it's the shit is the shit.
I mean,
you can't get mad at them for starting her own network for being smart enough to
do that.
I don't,
I don't hate on any of that shit,
but that whole fucking thing where all is right,
if,
if they win it is,
that's a little,
it goes a little beyond.
But other than that,
I don't begrudge their fucking 27 championships.
I really don't.
Um,
having said that,
we finally got the right people in place.
So you finally got the right people in place.
And having said that,
um,
whoever was going to win last night,
the cubs or the Indians was an automatic one way fucking a ticket for either
Theo Epstein or Terry Francona into,
uh,
into the hall of fame.
So congratulations to Theo Epstein.
Um,
without a doubt.
I mean that guy ended the curse of the baby and the curse of the goat.
I mean,
he needs a nickname at this point,
something right.
I can't think of it right now,
but I'm just saying that guy and 86,
[inaudible] 86 and 108,
that's 186 and 894 years of suffering.
That fucking guy just ended,
you know,
it was like a champ too.
You see the guy in his forties,
he still looks like he used to be an astronaut.
I mean,
the guy's just crushing it as somebody fucking levels.
You can really see how people would try to root against him and um,
whatever,
man,
the Indians will definitely be back.
I gotta be honest with you,
I'm still more of an Indians fan than I am a cubs fan,
but it was so fucking great,
like seeing the look of joy on,
on a bill Murray's face.
And by the way,
uh,
what Fred says,
God like,
did you not enjoy seeing that?
Watching him?
She's fucking Lens,
however old he is,
was all just fucking coming out.
It was tremendous.
So,
um,
it was great.
It was what a fucking gay man,
Jesus Christ,
what a go.
And then I forgot the fucking rain delay and then they tie it up.
They fucking tie it up.
And I was like,
oh my God,
this is on.
It's,
it's going to reverse again.
Like the way everyone's,
like,
everyone just kind of thought the cubs are going to win it.
And then the Indians got three games to one.
They're like,
oh my God,
the Indians are going to win it.
Then in reverse,
then it looks like the cubs are gonna win it.
And then the Indians tied fucking back up again and you're like,
fuck,
I know I'm getting hyped up here.
But Dude,
when,
when is baseball get this fucking exciting,
right?
And then it starts fucking raining and they bring out the fucking tarp.
That's the funniest shit.
And that's one of the great,
that's like the sport within the sport of baseball is the fucking rain delay.
And they got to put a book.
If there's never been a book put out yet about people just talking about what
goes through your head as you're going through a fucking rain delay and you have
to sit there and fill up three hours of fucking broadcast time telling you
stories.
I mean,
that's when you got to hope that you got like a,
uh,
a Pete rose there.
You know what I mean?
You got to have some guy with a zillion fucking stories that knows how to tell a
story.
Um,
dude,
he,
how great was he?
He was fucking phenomenal.
A rod was great.
The big heart,
all of those guys when you got like hall of famers sitting there,
you know,
just the way they break down for nobody breaks it down like Pete Rose,
Jesus Christ,
you know all the games that that guy has played,
all the experiences he's had and then you combine gambling on it.
So he took it to a whole other level of the way he looks at numbers.
I mean the is like second to none with his analysis.
By the way,
Jason Heyward,
huge fan,
that fucking catchy made,
I forget what game where he leapt up and then had to reach back and then when he
fired the,
the through that strike like Dave Parker and the all star game grant,
Dave through it from the warning track to the home plate when he threw in a
second to get that guy out kill the fucking momentum is great.
As that was the worst at bat of the fucking s of this series was his one of his
lasted bats.
Dude,
did you see the two pitches?
He fucking swung out.
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
50 cent could've struck him out at that a bad,
I mean it was,
it was like,
look where they just stayed.
Take some fucking guy like 50 cent out of the crowd and the,
Oh my God,
it's 50 cent and he just goes out and throws the ball.
You're like,
oh my God,
he really is an artist.
Um,
you got to look that up by the way.
I think I tweeted when he did that,
I said,
50 cent didn't throw that ball.
Curtis Jackson did.
You have to see him and it's just like,
it was a,
I dunno,
it was like watching Jon Lester trying to throw to first base,
which I had no idea that he,
he won't even do it.
I'm nuts.
Is that,
that's like a,
it was like chuck,
not Chuck Knob locked Steve Sax Times fucking to at least one of the videos that
I saw and thank God that he didn't.
But um,
anyways,
uh,
my condolences to the city of Cleveland,
man.
I,
I really,
I love that city and a municipal stadium.
I'll let shit back in the day that I grew up watching.
Like I said,
one of my relatives lived out there when I was a kid and he kind of would always
be rooting for them and you know,
he was cool.
So I would fucking route for him to a buddy,
of course,
red sox first.
So I always kind of had that thing with them and the Tigers that kind of like
the surrogates if the,
uh,
the red sox aren't in it.
Um,
and I also liked the royals and I like the A's.
I don't know.
I like the pirates.
I like the cardinals.
I like the giants and I liked the Dodgers back in the day.
So I know there's a lot of teams that I fucking thing,
you know,
they all take a deep second to fucking,
the red sox aren't in it,
you know what I mean?
So anyways,
I even rooted for the Yankees in 2001 after nine 11,
I was like,
I fucking,
I got to set this shit aside and then the fucking diamond back speeding.
It's like,
fuck,
I should have been rude for these guys the whole time.
I wouldn't jinxed him.
So anyways,
congratulations.
Uh,
and Cleveland.
Amen.
Your next,
or I guess I should be rooting for the Arizona cardinals cause they have the
longest drought,
I guess with the championship since 1947 when they were the Chicago cardinals.
Um,
and then they went to,
uh,
I don't,
I can't remember what the fucking lineage of that team is,
but like I don't give a fuck about them because they've lived in so many fucking
cities.
Like the city doesn't carry the pain.
Does that make sense?
Middle of Arizona cardinals right now.
Uh,
I'm surprised it didn't just pop up on my thing.
You know your computer like listens to you now I actually
get did Arizona cardinals,
you have to do that.
You just say,
yeah,
fucking a pumpernickel bread.
Oh,
what's in pumpernickel bread?
You break,
you break like p you and then it says pumpernickel bread.
Like your phone.
I'll do that.
Like who,
what the photo fucking odd.
Zach came up,
you'll listen to me.
Said fucking robot lady in the phone.
She listens,
right?
She listens to,
Oh yeah,
she's listening to you.
Let's see here.
Official site.
No,
it's pretty sad case.
She got to go to Wikipedia to find out their fucking history the quickest.
Actually.
Maybe it isn't.
All right,
here we go.
The cardinals,
let's see.
They were the Chicago cardinals,
1920 to 1943 they took a year off during the war.
1945 the 1959 uh oh they were the cardinals card pit in 1944 I thought they had
the eagles in Pittsburgh and made the struggles.
Anyway,
St Louis Cardinals,
1960 to 1987 Phoenix cartels 88 to 93 94 to present Arizona.
So they've been all right.
They've been cheated.
They've been in Phoenix for fucking almost 30 years.
Wow.
They've been there longer than they weren't St Louis.
How Jesus,
how about that?
And they were in Chicago
basically for 29 years.
Isn't that something?
So they weren't being Arizona the longest,
then Chicago,
then Saint Louis.
So anyways,
I don't really count that fucking shit.
Let's see,
the longest stretch.
I got to see the next person.
I give a fuck about pass Cleveland,
right?
Let's see.
Longest sports droughts,
Big Bang,
boom,
drought sports.
Uh,
longest active droughts in sports.
When was this?
May,
this was done three hours ago.
Okay.
So they should be fairly accurate.
Correct.
So it goes the Arizona cardinals,
then the Cleveland Indians.
Just give me the fucking list.
All right.
The Arizona cardinals shut up.
69 years.
Cleveland Indians,
68 years.
Sacramento,
kings 1951.
They will like to Rochester royals I think,
or some shit like that.
Uh,
they have a one in 65 years to Troy lion,
seven one since 1957.
The Atlanta Hawks when they were the Saint Louis Hawks,
1958,
uh,
then the Philadelphia Eagles,
1960,
uh,
Texas rangers.
Never 1955,
never won a championship.
Tennessee titans,
they used to be the Houston Oilers.
They want an AFL title in 1961.
It's a couple more here.
Houston Astros,
never 54 fucking years.
Um,
San Diego chargers,
1963 53 years since your AFL title,
and then the Toronto Maple leafs.
So if we're going to go sport by sport,
uh,
the longest drought and football's the Arizona cardinals baseball is the
Cleveland Indians.
Basketball is the Sacramento Kings in hockey is the Toronto Maple leafs.
There you go.
69 years,
68,
65 at 49.
So there you go.
Toronto
Shit.
These other guys,
they got,
they got fucking 20 years on you.
And actually nowadays when there's that many fucking teams,
you want to get 32 teams to go 50 years considering one of them's going to,
you know,
when a couple,
two,
three if not four or five over 30 years.
Right.
It's very easy now to go 40 years.
Okay.
All right,
Bill,
I think we've had enough of the sports talk.
All right,
well maybe I have to,
let's talk about flat top grills,
shall we,
by the way,
I have not called law head yet.
I'm going to wait three days.
I'm going to run and run into him.
I'm going to give him a hug.
You know,
tell him,
you know,
you still got the NBA title,
you've got a little hyped up there.
Oh my God.
The agony j law.
Remember that?
The agony of defeat.
Do you remember when the ski jump Guy went off to fucking ski jump?
If you look at j law had his Twitter feed,
dude,
it's fucking hilarious
because if he's not joking,
he's literally,
he goes off to ski jump like five times every game.
You know,
when,
and he's just laying face down and you're like,
is he dead?
Is he dead?
And then he somehow pops his head up,
shakes his hair out,
he puts the fucking goggles back on and he fucking gradually walks back up the
stairs again.
I'm telling you,
man,
it's,
it's really entertaining.
Anytime there's a big Cleveland game,
I recommend following Jay law had Jason Law head on,
um,
on Twitter.
You know,
just sit back and just watch the fights.
It's tremendous.
It's,
it's an amazing thing.
it's a great sports book.
Every fog and just,
just in tweets.
It's incredible.
All right.
So anyways,
let's talk about a flat top grill.
Everybody.
Oh,
I want to get a flat top grill.
Um,
I told you a few weeks ago when,
um,
John Fabulous,
you know,
was shooting some stuff that possibly,
I don't know,
he might do some footage with,
uh,
cooking at his place.
And I went over to the taping mean the lovely Nia and we got to hang out with a
chef Roy Choi who started the whole gourmet food truck thing.
A,
they cooked on a grill,
which is something I never did.
Even when I worked in a restaurant.
I cooked on a mesquite grill.
I did burgers,
shrimp,
brochette chicken sandwich whenever the fuck you want.
Right.
Um,
but I never worked with uh,
on,
on a griddle before and now,
uh,
I am,
I am so fucking into those things.
It's ridiculous.
And I found this one on the Internet.
I'm not going to tell you the name of it.
Just look up flat top fucking grill.
There's two.
It's not the Blackstone one.
This is like a smaller one.
It's more compact from my little la backyard.
And I'm trying to convince my wife to let me get it,
man.
You know,
cause we're re we're redoing the kitchen and so we went to go do the stove,
like the one that had the little griddle on it was just going to take up too
much counter space.
We have a small kitchen area and the number one thing was I hated the,
there like no prep area in the kitchen and I hate,
I hated the island.
Have ever told you guys how much I hate a fucking island in a kitchen.
I,
I don't,
I don't care if it can fit in my kitchen.
It couldn't fit.
They just put an island in there because it was like the fucking thing to do and
you just walk.
It's like having a fucking hippo that passed out on booze and it,
you just kind of walk around like the worst fucking thing is whatever you're at
the stove and whatever you need is diagonally across the other side of the
fucking hell.
You've got to walk all around it.
Okay.
Now for all my friends around the world in war torn countries,
this is what she complained about in the United States of America,
that God damn island in your fucking brand new kitchen.
Right.
Sorry.
But anyways,
so we didn't get the griddle and now I'm already kicking myself because we end
up going with this stove as six burners.
I'm like,
well there's two of us were like,
what the fuck do I want?
Even when we have Thanksgiving dinner,
I've never had more than three going at a time.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
You got something in the oven,
you've got something else.
And so you've got two sides,
maybe three sites,
right?
That's it.
You don't need six.
I should have got the fucking Gretel.
But then I saw this,
this attachment that you can get that you put the griddle on top,
but it's not the same cause now you kind of control on the heat with like the
burners.
So what I would do is I put one on simmer,
right or low,
and then the other one I'd cook,
put it up on the cook and heat.
So I can do that whole fucking thing of moving the food around.
You know,
if it's going too fast,
if it needs to chill,
if the,
that the bread's brown and up,
but the cheese hasn't melted yet.
All that shit that I learned.
If,
if Fabro ever puts that shit out,
dude,
I'm telling you,
man,
I learned more goddamn shit about cooking just with that,
controlling the heat and moving it around and actually looking at the stuff I
can't even,
I'm beside myself.
I immediately became 15 to 20% better cook than I was,
which isn't hard because I suck.
But,
um,
anyway,
so I started watching this guy.
You guys got to check this guy out on,
on,
on Youtube.
Um,
he actually promotes the grill that I wasn't going to get.
It's just a little too big for me,
but it's the Blackstone grill and there's this guy,
uh,
what the fuck does he call himself?
He goes by Todd Tovan,
And m.
What does he call himself?
Although Rocky Mountain meet hunter.
Okay.
All right.
He's on twitter@rockymountainmeethundred.com.
But you don't need to go to Twitter unless you want to just tell him you like
his videos,
but just watch this guy fucking Cook,
you know?
Uh,
I know he's hyping all these barbecue sauces and rubs and all that ship a good
fam.
The man's got to make a living,
but the shit that he makes is fucking unbelievable and a too,
when you see this griddle,
there's no fucking way,
just to let you guys know,
they make a smaller one,
um,
that I'm thinking about getting.
But a dude is fucking ridiculous.
He's making fucking cheese steaks.
He's making case of d is he made pizza in this other fucking thing.
He's toasting up the bonds.
He's got his onions,
peppers go,
and he's got elk on the grill.
Whatever the fuck you want.
I actually watched this guy was so inspired by a man in a frying pan.
I took some of that elk that Rogan gave me and I made late at night.
I made a,
um,
sort of my version of an elk cheese steak.
I had some peppers and onions going with a little bit of mushroom.
Right.
And then,
uh,
the meat that he gave me is more like hamburger.
So it was more of the consistency of hamburgers.
So I couldn't really lay it in.
I had to kind of poured into the urban,
but it put the,
uh,
you know,
the fucking,
uh,
the provolone on top.
I don't like the Wiz Dude.
I don't like the Wiz provolone on top.
I could have seasoned the meat a little bit more of just my salt shaker.
I don't know what it is.
I can't see it coming out.
It comes out.
So finally I was tasting it and I didn't want to oversalt it,
but I needed to,
I probably should put like,
I don't garlic salt or something like that in there,
but a little cheese on top with the mushrooms and then the peppers.
And then I had the best fucking role ever.
And I made this thing like one in the morning,
you know,
I was coming off from doing my spots and I made it.
And you know,
Nia sitting there going,
what are you,
two days too late?
Oh,
and then I made the thing,
I came walking in and she was like,
what is that?
Right.
And I gave her a bite and then of course,
you know she does that fucking shit.
I want one.
I'll look.
Oh it is.
Oh,
she just called and I missed a call.
Um,
anyways,
so I am crazy and to doing that.
So I'm thinking about getting that for the backyard.
We'll see.
He's already given me,
you know,
she,
she knows what she's doing.
She just sorta,
you know,
like when you really excited about getting something,
your wife just sort of just,
you know,
it was quiet and nods.
That means they don't want you to get it and they're just waiting for it.
Hoping that your excitement will go away after a couple of days.
But I do the same thing to her.
What's up buddy?
You,
you totally know how to work the angles,
don't you cleo?
Sometimes when she wants something rather than coming over and being crazy,
she just comes over and she just put her head on my leg and then just sort of
look at me,
you know,
how do you resist that Cleo kitchen?
Not Thank you.
Come on,
go lay down.
Go lay down.
Go on.
All right.
Um,
maybe read a little bit of advertising here for the week.
oh,
on it.
Speaking to Joe Rogan,
Joe Rogan's company on it.
I'm on.
It has a new product.
It's called a MOLST suffice MCT oil.
Mct Oil is one of the fastest sources of clean fuel for the body and the brain.
It's one of the best ways to power up your performance.
A kickstart,
a weight management program.
There are lots of MCT oil brands out there,
but there's none like emulsified MCT oil from Onnit available in three delicious
flavors,
coconut,
Vanilla and strawberry.
As I said,
that's all my three flavors.
I got a coconut and vanilla skin and strawberry emulsified MCT oil mixes like a
cream easily in your morning.
Coffee without the need for a blender.
No mess.
No,
you can even mix it right into your favorite foods right now.
If you go to onnit.com/bill you can get on,
it's emulsified MCT oil for 12% off.
That's o n n I t.com/bill to get emulsified MCT oil for 12% off.
And for any reason,
if you don't like it,
they'll give you your money back.
No questions asked.
No biggie.
You got nothing to lose.
Go to onnit.com/bill and get on it.
All right.
[inaudible] Ltd genes.
Jesus Christ,
uh,
Delta Sierra Lima,
Tango,
Delta genes.
The problem with jeans is that they're really,
that the really good pairs cost two to $300.
Isn't that the truth?
Easily in the bargain brands just fall apart.
It look terrible.
That's also true.
So you,
they have no money,
right?
Or,
uh,
you know,
your ass is hanging out with people.
Beat the shit out of you.
I mean that,
those are your two options.
You know,
unless you're,
you,
I know you're one of those fucking son's of a Saudi Arabian prince,
right?
And you just rolling barrels oil down the fucking stairs every morning.
Dst LD pronounced distilled.
I didn't know that actually I did,
but I forgot.
Has revolutionized the fashion industry by creating timeless luxury grade denim,
so you get genes that would cost you hundreds of dollars starting at just $65
this was my question.
How do they do it?
Let's see how they do it.
By refusing to work with department stores in retail middlemen,
there's no markup,
no bullshit,
just Greg chains at an unbelievable price.
Just go to distill.com spelled DST LD,
Delta,
Sierra,
tango,
Lima,
delta.com find the perfect pair with the perfect fit.
They'll ship them to you for free and guarantee the fit.
Or we'll send you a new pair till they are perfect or it doesn't say they'll
take it back.
They'll just keep shipping you and you ain't getting your money back.
You're going to get more jeans.
See for yourself.
Why a list celebrities have been spotted and magazines like vogue and Gq wearing
distilled jeans while you're fucking paid them too.
If you just spot them out back,
you know,
making a fucking hotdog without the bun.
Of course they got to keep the abs there.
Even c list celebrities like me,
I don't like how they made me trash myself.
I will do the trashing of me and I'm a c plus celebrity.
I got a cartoon on Netflix that makes me see,
plus I got a pair of raw denim and it,
the fit is amazing.
You know what's funny about this?
I have not gotten that yet.
You know my fucking producer on the show he's wearing and he said they're
fucking unbelievable and he wears them all the time.
All right,
so I never,
you know,
I got too much shit in my house.
So whenever these advertisers say,
we'll send you some stuff,
like I never take it,
but he's wearing them now and he's been raving about them so much.
Now I want a fucking pair.
And that's how it works.
That's how America works.
That's how you defeat isis.
Distilled is the only place in the u s where you can get this weight of denim
for this price point.
And with the natural indigo look.
Remember the indigo girls?
I went to the doctor,
I went down and my friend,
they're going to fit beautifully and for last four years.
Well,
you don't to be a story or have a stylist or even pay $100 to look amazing.
Just go to distilled.
Starts at 65 bucks.
Half off.
You're lucky if we get it.
Where the fuck did we go?
That's distill Dotcom,
Dstl d.com/birth for $10 off right now.
Five leverage,
five letters.
D S T l d.com/burr.
Oh,
that was fucking,
that.
That was,
I liked that.
I went to the doc.
I'm sorry.
All right.
Loot crate everybody giving.
You're going to,
uh,
be the envy of your friends.
Oh my God.
Look at him.
God,
I wish I was him.
What is,
what does the person doing the,
that this would be the envy of other people and get 100% exclusive crates at
[inaudible] dot com slash burr and enter my code burr to save $3 off any
subscription.
Well,
why do you want to be the envy of friends?
Why won't you let your friends know what's going on and y'all get a crate?
Jesus Christ,
Luke Crane,
you boxing yourself out,
get a,
get a fucking loot crate and tell all your friends about it so there's no envy
and they can all stand around.
Hey,
I like your wonder woman outfit.
Well thank you.
I like your Flash Gordon fucking wig.
I'm on a quest for epic gear,
housewares and collectibles.
Is that what you want to do?
Well,
loot crate has it.
Loot crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
Uh,
if you're a more of a fan fanatical,
I just want to know if they wonder woman's fucking drawers,
if one of those nerds,
they can put it on their fucking,
they can sleep next to it,
you know,
sniffing her and visible pussy.
Well,
she's done invisible issue her is,
it never made any sense.
Um,
if you're more of a fantastic,
but you can still,
every community did that big and still see her.
She should be invisible in it.
But then just for animation purposes,
then you'd have to be like,
you know,
well,
where is it would just showing clouds going by.
You know what's funny,
like this is probably like a 40 minute argument in the writer's room at Hannah
Barbera,
one of those fucking places a long time ago.
Back to the advertising.
If you're more a fan,
fanatical fashion Easter than try loot where monthly wearables and accessories
with cult classics and your favorite franchises.
I want to Hook Joe to Rosa up with this.
If you want to get fantasy,
get a bigger box and even bigger loop with loot crate DX.
Get ready for Novembers and Channing theme.
Magical Luke crane has a cast as cast,
a powerful ancient spelled to deliver you.
November's crate featuring be witching items from Dr. Strange,
not doctor strange love,
Dr. Strange,
fantastic beasts and where to find them.
Sorry.
They just ended and then it went to the next sentence,
but there was a gap there.
A big trouble in little China.
I love that movie and so much more.
Do not wait.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe for Novembers crate.
When it's over,
it's over.
No more crates.
Go to Luke crew duck loot,
crate.com loot crate dotcom slash.
Burn and am my code bar to say $3 off any new subscription today?
Luke coon.
Oh Jesus Christ.
How many more?
All right.
Two more.
Hang in there guys.
Hang.
Well,
how much time is left me?
They'll fuck around a little more and then I'll read the last of these.
All right,
we'll fuck around a little more.
Um,
all right.
What did I want to talk about?
Oh,
fucking who's playing this week?
Who's playing this week in college football?
Anything?
Do I actually have anything else that I want to talk about other than the fact
that I liked making Hash Brown snuff.
Oh boy.
I tell you guys how much I enjoy making fucking Hash and take your breakfast to
the next level with the griddle.
Make it some.
Fuck that.
You know something.
If he is ever just want to shut people the fuck up,
just make some hash browns.
Start them off.
The cheesy ones,
and then you bake them in the oven and just shut everybody the fuck up.
If you want to shut me the fuck up.
That's basically what you can do.
Hey,
shout out to Steve Bartman everybody.
Hey Dude,
stay in hiding,
man.
Don't,
don't let those cons draw you back out.
All right?
They had the chance to be friends with a great person like you.
You know they're going to try to ask you to go to the parade,
you know?
Oh,
all is forgiven.
All is forgiven.
You know,
it was just fucking 13 years of health.
Um,
do you guys think he goes,
do you think he goes back?
I don't think he does.
He said no to 30 for 30 kind of.
Seems like he would just,
he,
you know,
he's a very commendable person.
He was somebody that has no desire for fame in this century,
which is a,
you know,
more than I can say for myself in 90% of the other people out there.
So God bless them.
All right.
Actually,
I have one questionnaire usually don't read questions on the Thursday afternoon
podcasts.
All right.
Tom Steele.
Yo Billy Ginger tits.
Yes,
I did enjoy the two hour podcasts,
but you're wrong about one thing.
It's not illegal for women to show their titties or even go topless in most of
the United States.
I didn't know that.
In fact,
33 states have laws specifically allowing it.
However,
certain towns,
cities,
and municipal areas within each of these states prohibits to practice a sighting
disturbing the peace as a misdemeanor,
as interpreted by law enforcement sometimes incorrectly.
Uh,
if you're digging it,
okay.
I,
this is the deal dude.
Like I guess,
you know,
in Africa and some of these other countries,
they walk around with their titties out.
I guess people don't give a shit about it.
It's like not a big deal.
They get used to it like seeing a woman's legs or whatever.
If women want to do this shit,
I've come full circle.
Fuck it.
You want to walk around with the Goddamn titties out?
I don't know why you'd want to,
I gotta be honest with you.
Most men should not be walking around with his shirt off.
Like this should be a rule.
Okay.
You want to have your shirt off.
Either you're at the beach,
you're in your own backyard or you're working on a chain gang fucking digging a
trench in the side of the road.
Okay.
If you're actually working for a fucking live and you want to take your goddamn
shirt off and risk skin cancer,
by all means do it.
Okay?
Believe me,
there's a lot of guys with their shirts out there.
They've got big tits than most of the women out there.
So,
um,
I just think it's a funny thing that like,
yeah,
I just don't understand why women were just like,
why can't we do it?
They just,
they,
they just have that fee maybe cause it's the position they are in society the
way men kept them down for so fucking long that every last fucking thing that we
do,
they want to do regardless of how fucking stupid it is.
You know what I mean?
Who Fuck wants to walk around with their shirt off.
Okay.
Matthew mcconaughey,
people like that.
People don't like p nine zero x shape,
like walking around without this shirt.
How,
which makes sense.
She did the work.
God bless you.
I've never had a desire to walk around with my fucking shirt off.
Yeah.
Why would you be half?
Especially past a certain age,
you got to start covering up 48 fucking years old.
You don't want to see a half naked anything.
There's a few out there.
Madonna kept herself in great shape.
You know what I mean?
There's a few people out there.
They've kept themselves,
you know,
and in phenomenal shape.
They can take their fucking shirts up.
But for the most part,
most people by 23,
24,
by all means,
man.
A man,
a woman,
keep the fucking shirt on.
Yeah.
I don't know.
That's just one of those things.
I mean,
it's like listening to somebody complain about the island in their kitchen.
It's just like,
don't you have anything better to focus on?
All right.
The hypocrite continues.
Um,
so I guess,
uh,
let's see.
Claiming equal topless rights for men and women go topless.
There's something here.
Uh,
go topless claims that women have the same constitutional right,
that men have to go bare chested and public.
Uh,
I'd really disagree with that to try to say like,
our titties are the same as your titties might my titties can't get me around a
drinks.
You know what I mean?
If I show half a fucking man peck hair that doesn't get me anything,
or maybe I'm just in the wrong bars,
maybe I need to go into a gay bar there too.
That's a great youtube video.
Go into a gay bar and dress like a man or and see how long you can drink for
free.
There would be fucking hilarious.
Then at the end of the night,
the guy's like,
hey man,
see,
you want to get out of here?
Be like,
yeah,
but I'm not going home with you and be like,
dude,
what the fuck about show his drinks?
We were like,
yeah,
well,
I'm straight.
Well,
what the fuck are you doing here?
I just want,
I wanted to drink for free.
Then he goes to swing.
You just go,
no,
me.
Right,
and you get out of their drinking a bunch of Budweiser's simply safe.
It's crazy what engineers are coming up with these days.
The engineer invented the simply safe home security system was attending Harvard
University.
When his friends got robbed,
he wanted to help them out.
So they started shopping around for home security.
But all the security companies at the time were just awful.
They'd sell these clunky,
expensive systems that required all sorts of drilling to install and to get
them,
you had to sign it.
Huge longterm contract.
That's what I did.
So this guy,
simply safe to try and fix all the problems with the security industry.
Simply safe is wireless.
There's no drilling.
I did all of this to my house.
You don't have to put a bunch of holes in your walls to keep your family safe.
Got dammit.
This is why.
Why buy anything?
Because then they always come up.
Oh,
just hovers in the fucking air.
Anyway.
Simply safe is wireless.
All right.
Um,
there's no longterm contract.
You don't have to pay for something.
You're not using 24,
seven monitoring.
It's just 1499 a month.
That's three times less than other security companies.
Fucking cock suckers.
Visit simply safe bird.com today with the 60 day money back guarantee and a
three year warranty.
You've got nothing to worry about.
Plus go today and get a free shipping and a free key chain remote you can arm
and disarm your system with the push of a button that's simply safe.
bird.com simply safe bird.com fuck
okay.
No,
Jesus.
Well,
what do I feel like everything in my house is the technological equipment of a
fucking laserdisc player.
I'm going to look into those guys and see what the fucking deal is.
All right.
Seek everybody.
This is the last thing.
Buying tickets online for sports and concerts has been a confusing process for a
long,
long time.
It's always been hard to find the best deal for that game or show you want to go
to and none of those older tickets sites want to charge that.
Change that sorry,
but seek is different.
They've come along and created an amazing APP and website that makes it easier
than ever for fiber,
for fans to buy and sell tickets.
Siki does all the price comparisons for you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get the best possible deal and seek,
wants to help you get the most bang for your buck.
That's why every ticket on seek geek is given a grade based on value.
You'll immediately see any underpriced seats to be able to find the best deals
that fit your project.
Best of all,
my listeners get $20 off a $20 rebate off their SeatGeek purchase.
To get your $20 rebate on tickets,
download the SeatGeek APP,
go to settings,
go to the settings tab and click add a promo code.
Enter the Promo Code Burr Seatgeek will send you $20 off after you made your
first ticket purchase.
Download seat.
Keke the seat Geek App and enter the Promo Code bird today.
All right.
That's it for the advertising.
That is it for me.
Congratulations once again to all the Chicago Faithful,
uh,
to the other 80% that showed up.
Congratulations to you too.
And the band wagons,
um,
Micah dawn says to Cleveland fans,
you did get the calves this year.
Uh,
you do have Terry Francona,
you've got great players and uh,
yeah,
I mean,
I dunno,
we won one with Manny Ramirez and everybody else to so many like the Phillies,
Yankee fans,
red sox fans,
all should have been rooting for Cleveland because we all use your fucking CCS,
your Manny Ramirez,
your Jim Tommy's.
We all use those guys to get our championships and uh,
also that Petrou fucking pitch for everyone and forgot his fucking name wasn't
curt Floyd.
Was it Cleo?
How's it?
Can I get a whole of here before we go?
That's kind of the sign off now.
Hey Cleo,
you want to go outside?
Okay.
Down,
down.
No jumping.
Cleo.
Cleo not fight Cleo
to you.
Oh,
she almost did.
She just got up.
Come on.
Come on you guys.
You know your commute is long enough.
You can hang it in the first clip set.
Set
cleo
to,
she's not going to do it today.
Cleo,
I think the specimen we get out of it.
Alright,
go fuck yourselves.
Congratulations to the cubs.
My consultants is the Cleveland Indians and I'll,
I'll see you on Monday.
Have a great weekend.
You can listen to.
These are greatest sets after this music.
Oh,
Jesus.
Okay,
well the dust.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's still Ba.
It is
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 27th,
2008 and the Year of our Lord Jesus Christ.
Uh,
what is this,
the year four?
Are you Catholic?
What do we do?
I know that the Chinese people,
he always got,
you know,
the year of the Yak.
And why is it,
that's always my default animal Yak.
It's just funny.
I'm sorry.
I don't even,
what the fuck it is.
What is a Yak?
That's your homework for this week.
If you're a regular listener,
let me know what a Yak is and what,
where are they indigenous to?
Okay,
I'm going to go out on a limb and I'm going to say,
uh,
I'm going to say Scotland.
I don't think there's any JAKKS over here.
The raw JAKKS over here,
they were brought here against their will.
Much like those people from Africa.
And you know,
I think it's high time that they made an Omnistar for fucking JAKKS.
You know,
what about all the livestock?
What about the fucking Dodo Bird?
You know,
what about the,
the fucking lamaze here.
We just shouldn't be in the middle of nowhere and somebody has a fucking Lama,
you know,
how did it get there?
That thing doesn't have a story.
That thing doesn't it need to go,
you know,
check out his family tree and figuring out where the fuck it came from.
What the hell was I?
I was in,
no,
I was in Richmond,
Virginia and I'm driving down the street with the guy who works over there,
buzz with one Z who was one of my favorite people in comedy.
The guys literally 60 years old and he's still hits on like 22 year olds and he
creeps them out every time he does it and he doesn't give a shit.
And uh,
you know,
I've got to respect them for that.
But anyways,
we're driving in the radio station and there,
there's a fucking Lama in the middle of Richmond,
Virginia.
And uh,
you know,
I really wanted to know why.
You know,
what exactly,
what do people do with llamas?
They would tell you guys that I love goats if ever told you that shit.
Like the goat is the perfect pet for me because I have,
I like to fuck and I have a tendency to fuck with animals.
You know what I mean?
I fuck with people and it doesn't stop there.
You know,
I don't know what it is.
I started playing with the puppy and then eventually I roll him over on his
back.
I semi sorta hold him down,
which gets him all fucking,
uh,
you know,
all aggressive.
And next thing you know,
they take a bite out of my hand,
you know,
take a chunk out of me.
So that's why I don't have a fucking dog because I turned them into a,
those dogs you see on the news that need to get put down.
So I found goats actually enjoy that shit.
Then when you look in,
you know,
when you're,
when you're looking the other way,
I'd go to take a run at.
Yes.
You know,
they're like a dirty player and uh,
it was,
it was a classic dirty player from way back in the fucking day.
I even Chris [inaudible] and Chris Island,
you know,
he would do some shit.
He did.
Rick Milton in the mouth with is the butt end of his stick.
That's kind of a dirty,
but I know he was never really into boarding.
I'll Samuelson.
That's what it goes.
Is that the goal is the all Samuelson a fucking farm animals.
Every time you got your head down and you're facing the bar and the thing,
I'll take a run at ya.
And the problem is it never gets suspended from the league.
All right.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
My name is bill burr.
I mentioned that earlier.
And uh,
currently I am in the midst of the uh,
the uninformed a radio tour,
which a is uninformed,
the radio show I do with Joe to Rosa and the two of us around on tour right now
to hype the show and things are going great.
And our next stop is going to be in,
uh,
Washington DC.
The weekend of,
uh,
you know what,
I don't know what fucking weekend it is.
I think it's the first weekend in November.
Let me go here and go on to my new fancy website.
If you guys checked it out yet.
If you're not on my website right now and you're on my myspace page,
you know,
don't do it now cause you lose the fucking podcast.
But at the end of it,
go to [inaudible] dot com and a,
it's a brand new sleep website with a bunch of sexy photos of me,
um,
that make me look like I'm a lot cooler than I am.
All right.
November 6th through the eighth,
I'll be at the Improv in Washington DC on the uninformed tour,
me and Joe to Rosa and on,
uh,
the 11th November or sorry,
November 13th through the 15th,
we'll be at Zany comedy club in Nashville,
Tennessee.
And uh,
the next big data after that is going to be a Caroline's in New York City,
uh,
December 4th through the seventh.
And if anybody cares on December 8th,
I will be at the La Forum.
Am I going to be doing stand up?
No,
I'm not.
I'll be watching ACDC.
ACDC at the La Forum.
Did I tell you guys my pumpkin died?
My pumpkin?
I mean technically,
I don't know.
Well,
when does a Pumpkin Pie,
this is going to get like the pro life pro choice pumpkin people up in uh,
up in an uproar here when,
when exactly does a Pumpkin,
like what,
what's going,
you know,
that's just so much shit I don't know in life.
Is this stem was that was that it's fucking umbilical cord and you set it free.
Now it goes off to live a life and hopefully not marry the wrong person,
you know,
and get divorced and end up on a Fuckin futon or the second you snip that the
does is the function.
The function is the fucking pumpkin dead.
The function.
It's a good name for a band.
Come up on stage playing fucking P funk with Pumpkin's on your heads.
And you know,
if he had a catch phrase,
you could be a huge comedian and you could play the La Forum.
Now,
seriously,
this is what I learned with Pumpkins.
All right?
Don't call him three weeks before because they die in your refrigerator and it
makes you sad and you got to throw them out and nobody even got to see him.
So,
uh,
so I got to make another one.
I have to make another one.
You know what?
This is just classic me and my fucking podcast.
I started talking about some shit and I forgot where the fuck I was going.
And now here I am.
Here I am pulled over the side of the road,
looking at the map,
trying to figure out,
all right,
let's go to the questions.
Uh,
you're new to my podcast.
Um,
I do,
uh,
answer questions every week.
People email me,
they email me at bill at [inaudible] dot com or they go to my myspace page and I
try to answer as many as I can.
And,
um,
you know,
people try to enlighten me like a,
what is a Yak?
You know,
what does a Yak?
Is that like a fucking druggie cow with its hippie hair?
You don't want to fucking Google a fucking Yak right now.
And I'm looking at the image.
How do you spell yak?
It's not why a c k that means you puked.
Speaking of which two,
you know when I was looking at all the different pumpkin pictures,
you know ideas for Pumpkin.
That one where you,
where you carve a pumpkin faced with its mouth open and then you take the inside
of the Pumpkin and place it around the mouth and it looks like it puked is very
hacky.
They must've been 80 pumpkin's like that,
that Jesus Christ.
Look at that.
That's a fucking Yak.
Wow.
Okay.
It's got some Ma don't fuck with me.
Horns.
Looks like a,
looks like a Texas longhorn that needs a haircut.
He is a Guy Melkin one.
I was that a woman.
Hang on a second.
Yak uses.
You guys want to learn about JAKKS.
Here we go.
Statue of Golden Jakks in downtown Tibet.
Exactly
the fuck are JAKKS doing over here.
The YAC is truly the treasure of the plateau.
Well,
why don't you let me be the judge of it.
I hate when people make up my mind for me.
All right.
Evidently this Douche bag says it's the treasure of the plateau.
Well,
what is its competition?
I'm the gopher.
All right.
As the inscription reads below,
the Golden Statue of Jakks is in a busy intersection in downtown La,
Hoffa in the mountain,
Tundra and ice desert of the Tibetan plateau with altitude,
altitude soaring over 19,000 feet.
Jakks flourish where other domestic DCE die because of this.
People inhabiting this region use the Yag for everything.
Okay.
That's an open ended sentence.
So they obviously use it as a food source.
There's a girl milking one,
some to Ben Lady and uh,
they use it for everything.
Okay.
Uh,
you lifting the tail up and doing something disgusting that's on Youtube or is
it more tube eight?
The AKC is in escapable in La Hasa.
The acrid,
slightly sour smell of yak butter permeates the streets.
Okay.
I guess I'll never be going to lots of,
who the fuck wants to smell sour butter at 19,000 feet?
I,
you know,
something I would not be able to keep the look of disgust off my face.
And then they all start speaking in Tibet and thinking that I was some American
who thought they were above people rather than,
dude,
there's a fucking pungent smell you over at pungent into the mainstream was will
Ferrell in a anchorman.
Pungent stings the nostrils.
Um,
all right,
so it's,
it permeates the streets and temples where pilgrims burn the whitish yellow fat
and innumerable altars and carry smoking candles through the streets.
You have me just think a live in like death.
It was lady milk at a Yak,
no laptop,
no iPhone dress like an Apache everyday.
Just reach underneath some fucking Jakks UTR.
And then you go,
you don't have to go down to,
uh,
go down and get a smoothie.
Yak Milk is golden in color and very rich and fat at 70 to 80%.
And why the fuck is she so skinny and as a Swedish taste?
Then why did you just describe it?
You know,
you know what?
Fuck this website.
He said sour smell and now you're saying it's a sour smell with a Swedish taste.
Maybe that's why their eyes are so squinty.
It's not because their eyes.
I like that because it confused is there.
It doesn't make sense.
You know,
it's not sour that they fell asleep.
No.
Protection from Jakks is seasonal hybrid JAKKS oh good.
Okay.
Everybody's on the global warming and I want to,
I want to far to,
they have like 90% less.
Uh,
uh,
goddamn.
It's on the tip of my tongue.
What the fuck kind of gas is in cow's gas
against with an m methane.
Maybe JAKKS have less methane gas.
Is that the green people?
They're going to do that.
Eat a Yak Burger instead.
All right.
I think I'm sick of yaks at this point.
You guys take a good,
you know,
and I felt that you were like,
all right,
bill enough with the fucking JAKKS.
Um,
so anyway,
they're in Tibet and next time I do a road gig and like fucking Austin or
something,
I swear to God on a drive by and be like,
what the fuck is that?
And some guy names,
you know,
fuck with oneF is going to be like a,
that's a Yak.
What is it doing here?
I don't know.
Body.
I don't know about you.
I'll just take you the radio station.
Why don't you just focus on that being funny.
It's spelled sell some more fucking tickets.
You know what I mean?
How many fucking specialty you need to have before he can fill up a fucking
comedy club?
Why don't you get a catch phrase?
Why don't you just go on stage and just talk about JAKKS for fucking hour and
then you can be the fucking Yak guy and I wouldn't have to drive you to the
fucking radio station because you would have sold out second.
They put your fucking name up.
You ever think about that will then shut the fuck up then.
Okay.
Um,
all right,
so let's get on with the podcast questions.
Hey Bill,
have you ever auditioned for SNL when you lived in New York City?
That group seems to be clickish,
but I wondered if Lauren Michaels ever gave you a chance to be on the show.
You know what?
I can't remember if I auditioned for a SNL or mad TV,
but it was about nine years ago and I know I bombed because I went in there with
jokes rather than characters I had.
I would have like a quick care,
I'd have a character and then just do a quick joke about them and then move on
to something else.
Like I remember one of my characters,
I played a guy who was in the Klan who had a speech impediment.
He gets blocked on Edwards and I just remember part of the audition and me
staying there,
going new noon to noon and then that just sort of ended and everyone was looking
at me like I had fucking 12 heads.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I mean don't think the reason why I'm not on SNL is because it's clickish.
It's probably because Lauren has watched that tape at some point and projectile
vomited.
All right,
go.
Me and a friend at work run a celebrity death pool.
If you don't know what this is,
here it is in a nutshell.
You put an x,
you put x amount of a month and then you get a list of randomly picked potential
people who may die very soon.
You know what I noticed?
Celebrity depth full is,
and you didn't really describe it.
Well,
basically you a,
you pick not random people.
You pick,
you pick random celebrities,
famous people who you think are going to die.
I thought it was in a calendar year.
I guess they do it every month because these guys have a gambling promise that
basically you'd be like,
you know what?
I think a fucking Lisa Lu c or whatever the fuck her name is,
Lucy Lu.
I think she's going to uh,
eat some bad Sushi and a,
yeah,
it's we filming over in Japan and what's,
what's that Sushi that they eat over there?
Some sort of,
if you eat the wrong part of it,
you could fucking die.
And there's some macho thing to eat it.
She's going to go do that,
you know,
to prove she's one of the guys and she hangs out with the crew when she's going
to die like that.
That's what you would do.
All right.
The payout happens only when cnn.com announces it.
Oh,
this is the,
their rules.
Okay.
I'm back to the question now.
The obvious favorites or people like Fidel Castro,
Barbara Bush,
Amy Winehouse,
that midget from Austin Powers.
That's a good one.
Patrick Swayze,
et cetera.
Well,
every month everyone in the pool gets to pick a wildcard who wasn't on the
original roster.
Well,
I took a lot of shit this past week.
Ah,
I don't want to read this.
I don't want to read this because I don't want to put ideas in people's heads.
I'm sorry.
I just,
you know what?
I got you guys all excited and don't know.
I'm not fucking reading that one.
Um,
all right,
Bill.
I recently grew a beard.
There's a lot of social commentary on this.
Uh,
these questions this week.
Bill,
I recently grew a beard and had an argument with a gay guy that I work with.
He told me that all men with beards are gay.
That must've really killed your fucking idea growing a beard.
So,
uh,
he says,
and my whole argument was where to gay people get off just claiming something as
their own just because they like it.
Am I the only one who thinks that they can get away with this logic that they
can get away with?
His logic is fucking crazy.
You know,
wax eyebrows and going can't to tanning salons.
I'll give him that one.
But a beard,
when I think of people with beards,
I don't think gay,
I think lumberjacks swinging axis that's kind of gay bent over his tree thumb.
Did you ever see that Monty python sketch?
I'm a lumberjack and I don't care.
Have a good [inaudible] but uh,
and eventually it gets gay or,
and dare and float out of fucking dresses and dress just like me.
Mom,
he's on my jacket.
He don't care.
He fucking sucks cock and he likes the Bulls.
Um,
anyways,
when he thinks of a beard,
he thinks of lumberjacks swinging access like that job still exist.
Don't they have fucking chain sounds at this point?
Playoff hockey.
Yup.
I'll give you that.
And I think that's some gay people.
Some in quotes,
gay people have gotten way too comfortable in society.
Those bastards.
Where do they get off being uncomfortable?
Cause if he lived in the south and not New York City,
he'd be dragged behind a truck for saying that all men with beards are gay.
And not that I condone that behavior,
but maybe some gays have it coming to them.
Jesus Christ.
Then he writes.
That's all really.
Is that off?
Uh,
you know,
you pop off at the mouth.
There are consequences if you would your thoughts please.
I'll tell you what happened.
I think you're a little uncomfortable with gay people and you wanted to grow a
beard and you are all set on growing it.
And then some Gig I came up maybe realizing that you are homophobic decided to
fuck with your head.
And he said,
all men with beards are gay.
And it pissed you off because you thought this was going to be some rugged shit
that was going to get you some pussy.
And as you grow in it,
you can't get that guy out of your head going all men with beards again.
So here's my number,
sweetie.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't think all men with beards are gay.
Um,
and I think a lot of times when you see a guy with a beard who is gay,
you can tell because it's too manicured.
Just to George Michael ask,
you know what I mean?
But you gotta you gotta you do have to manicure it to a certain point manicure.
That's such a [inaudible] that's fucking nails,
whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
You got to trim it.
It's two landscapes,
but you know,
you've got to keep it off.
Your neck hurts.
It's just itchy is fucking hell.
Uh,
no,
I don't think beards are gay.
Um,
I think I thought more like hipster guys do it,
you know,
and all these hipsters are trying to dress like they're,
uh,
they're in the Beastie boys sabotage video.
You know,
they're trying to dress that way,
but there's this air of,
Oh,
I didn't even notice.
You know,
I just accidentally dressed like I was in the 70s.
Um,
what are my thoughts?
My thoughts are basically,
dude,
I think that if you want to grow a beard,
you should grow a beard.
And I think if a gay guy in down south said all guys who have beards are gay,
I would like to think that people would just laugh and still grow a beard if
they want it to rather than get all uncomfortable to the point that they'd want
to drag a gay guy behind the truck and beat the shit out of him.
Uh,
I don't think anybody has a comment on in that instance.
You know what I mean?
Um,
but if I was gay,
I would probably be careful of who I said that to.
Considering there are people out there who feel that people who do that should
be dragged behind a truck and get,
you know what?
You know what in a way the person is right.
When you do run your mouth,
there are consequences cause you don't realize who the psychos are.
This guy seems a little psychotic,
a little psychotic.
He doesn't condone the behavior,
but he's just saying,
Jesus,
can we have a lighthearted question here where I don't have to,
you know?
Okay.
Question a bill.
I was having a cigarette outside a restaurant last week and a guy who is missing
both arms comes over telling me to put it out because I was disturbing him with
my secondhand smoke.
All right,
you guys just making this shit up.
This really seems made up,
but you know,
just for the comedy of it,
I'll go with it.
He was wearing a muscle shirt.
Okay.
I'm guess I'm still going to believe this.
He was wearing a muscle shirt completely exposing his nubs.
I jokingly told this guy,
I'll put it out if he beats me at a game of rock,
paper,
scissors and it's questions bullshit.
You didn't say this eight is it bullshit?
This is even if he had a muscle tee shirt on,
even if he had no arms and even if he fucking came over and told you to put out
the cigarette,
it is no way you said it.
If you beat me,
if I'd be,
if he beats you had a game of rock,
paper,
scissors,
you know this.
That's like the shit you wish you said when he left.
But I will go with it.
Okay.
You know,
far be it for me to say and the people align to me.
All right.
Or exaggerating.
So evidently after he did this,
I'm the guy went off,
the guy went off on me and I felt bad.
So I put it out,
oh,
after you destroy the guy
and I put it out,
I pissed him off and I was like,
all right,
there you go.
There's the question.
Should amputees or people with horrific physical deformities warn you about it
before starting starting you with they're terrifying.
Handicap.
All right,
that's hilarious.
What was he supposed to do?
Like be on the other side of whatever building dairy queen you were sitting on
and be like,
why?
God is like,
you know,
I don't have any items that I'm wearing a tank top,
bottom color out of the car.
So if you want to finish your soft serve and not get startled,
you know,
you got three seconds to close your eyes.
Um,
you know,
something that is a,
that is,
yeah,
it's,
it's one of those things where you're not trying to be mean.
I don't know.
I can't speak for you,
but for me personally,
you know,
you're not trying to be,
uh,
you know,
insensitive.
But you know,
if you haven't been to war or you don't work in an emergency room,
they,
yeah.
There are shit that you're not expecting,
but you know,
you kind of roll with it.
Um,
I don't think that they should have to warn you about it,
but I don't know what you have to do as a person to become more used to it.
I don't know.
You know what?
Sometimes sometimes I don't have the answers.
I'll tell you.
It's fucked up.
Have you guys seen the new show on MTV called scarred?
It's insane.
It's basically footage of people trying to do tricks on bikes and skateboards
and on rollerblades and it's not the funny,
Oh,
when he lands on his nuts,
it's bones popping out of the skin.
And I'm going to tell you something,
dude is fucking unwatchable.
And uh,
it was so twisted and sick.
I actually sent a text message to ob from the OPN Anthony show to tell him to
get footage of it because it just seemed like such an opiate Anthony show clip,
you know,
they already did two girls,
one cup.
Now they could do a thing where,
you know,
can you sit here and watch bones come out of somebody's fucking hand?
Oh,
brutal.
All right.
Um,
okay.
Real quick.
Overrated.
Underrated.
Neal.
Pert of rush.
Awesome drummer.
But he gets way too much credit.
You know what?
I would,
uh,
I would definitely say he's an awesome drummer,
but yeah,
he's too robotic.
I don't hear the,
uh,
I don't hear a groove.
I liked John Bonham like I'm way better.
All right.
Underrated Comic Louie Ck saw him about three times and he kills each and every
time.
Oh Louise.
One of my favorite comics of all times.
I think he's fucking unbelievable and he blows me away.
So,
um,
if somebody is saying he isn't,
then yeah,
he is definitely underrated.
All right.
But not amongst Comedians,
I can tell you that.
All right,
last question.
Bill.
Here's a podcast question for Ya.
Uh,
your business is comedy,
right?
So let me ask you,
do you run the business or does the business run you hope?
You know what I mean?
Chairs.
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't know what you mean.
Do I run the business as you mean my personal business or show business?
I definitely do not run.
Show business.
Are you,
do you mean do I take the time to fly a kite each day and reflect on the fact
that I'm alive or do I just sit here and do podcasts and fucking tried to
attempt to finish blogs and shit?
Um,
I don't know.
It depends on the day.
Depends on the day.
I got my first massage and about eight months and legal,
by the way.
And,
uh,
I felt great after it and I've,
I've decided that I was going to start doing that.
You know,
you know me,
you know,
I have fucking OCD,
so I was like,
I want to do it every week.
You know,
I'll spend 50 grand a year on
massages,
which would cause stress.
You know,
I really gotta do something about my,
my,
I,
I'm just like,
I just realized that I'm going to be in Nashville,
Tennessee and before I do Nashville,
the Wednesday before I do Nashville,
I'm going to do the Bob and Tom Show in Indianapolis.
And I was thinking,
well,
you know,
I'm trying to go to every sports fucking team for some dumb reason.
And I'm literally contemplating driving down to go to a Memphis grizzly game
after I do Bob and Tom.
It's like a 400 mile drive.
And then after the game I would then have to drive over to Nashville and get
there in time to check in,
fall asleep,
and then do the radio in the morning.
And,
uh,
I'd like to tell you that I'm not going to do it,
but I think I'm going to do it and possibly hang around and drive up to the
Cincinnati Bengals game on a Sunday.
It's pathetic,
right?
But,
uh,
I dunno.
I think I'm going to do it.
Am I running from something or am I just a fucking maniac?
I Dunno.
I Dunno what,
but I can tell you this.
Um,
you guys don't need to worry about my fucking problems.
Let's wrap up this podcast.
I think it was a very good podcast.
We learned,
uh,
and some social commentary and,
we learned about Jakks,
learned about my OCD.
We learned about Pumpkin and you guys will learn about pumpkin carving.
Something that I learned when I was watching Martha Stewart,
who I can't stand watching.
It just so happened that I wanted to carve a pumpkin and I was flipping through
and I saw pumpkin and I stopped and she sat there with her cold demeanor.
When you're poor Korea,
one of the things you want to do,
cause she just seems like she'd be the worst mother ever.
Like couldn't hug you,
couldn't,
she couldn't show love and would just,
you know,
could never admit when she's wrong and Oh Geez,
I'm fucking projecting right now.
Um,
so basically what you want to do with the Pumpkin,
what I learned is you want to Lee area the side where you're going to be carving
into.
You want to make that as thin as humanly possible.
That way when you light the candle inside of it,
it glows this bright orange.
So if you carve something
scary or something like that,
it's the shit.
I really got to figure out how to upload pictures from my cell phone onto my
computer cause you gotta see this ACDC pumped.
And then I met,
you know what?
Now I'm going to hype it up so much and be like,
dude,
it really didn't live up to the hype and then I'll be hurt.
And uh,
which would be the reverse of what I wanted to do.
The reverse of the exercise of carving a Pumpkin was for me to be a happier
human being,
more peace.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's fucking wrapped us up.
I say this every week and then I keep going.
Let's,
let's re hype the gigs I rights I have.
Um,
I'll be at the Improv,
Washington DC November 6th through the eighth.
After that I'll be at xannies comedy club November 13th through the fucking
15th.
And,
um,
hey,
you know what?
I'm going to go to that God damn Bengals game.
What do you think about that?
Any listeners in Cincinnati,
you got an extra fucking ticket.
Let me know.
I'll come up to your tailgate.
We'll fucking eat some ribs that you cook out so you don't have,
I'll be like,
uh,
I'll be like a,
has been celebrity.
How'd you show up?
Like,
this is what my,
uh,
my career has come to you.
Gotta you gotta pay me an in fucking smoked ribs and I'll show up to your
tailgate.
Um,
and,
uh,
all I know one last thing,
we're going to be taping another episode of uninformed.
We always,
uh,
pre,
pre-taped these things.
I'm going to try to get some clips of it up on a uninformed radio,
my face.com/uninformed radio and a big news,
our guest is going to be Joe Perry from Aerosmith.
It's a long story how I ended up meeting somebody who was related to him and uh,
somehow it all came together and I'm hoping I don't make an ass of myself when I
interview him because I'm a huge fan and uh,
so whatever.
So I will let you know when that episode is going to air and we will definitely
start trying to get a audio clips from the show because people seem to like the
very special,
uh,
what was it,
Thursday,
Monday morning podcasts that I taped before this one,
if you want to go into the archives.
All right,
that's it.
I'm babbling.
It's not funny anymore.
It's just torture.
All right.
Hope all you guys have a good week.
Please keep the questions coming and I'm really enjoying them.
The,
the underrated overrated.
And,
uh,
if there's anything that I said that you felt was wrong and you'd like to
educate me,
or if I asked any questions,
I know I asked about JAKKS.
Why don't you,
why don't you tell me about llamas?
How about that?
Where,
where they're indigenous to for some reason,
I'm thinking the Arab community.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
I'm rubbing my face,
which means I'm exhausted.
Or is that stress?
Maybe it's stress.
Maybe I got too much shit to do.
So thanks for listening to the Monday morning podcast.
As always,
keep all this stuff coming in and,
uh,
please come out to my shows and,
that plus all your hope.
Y'All have a good week.
All right.
Take it easy.
Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's the Monday morning podcast.
You know,
I realize I start every podcast by saying,
hey,
what's going on?
I got to come up with something else.
Well,
maybe I should,
maybe I should brand that.
Like that guy,
uh,
Michael buffer or,
the,
uh,
the big bouncer looking guy from the UFC,
you know,
when he goes,
are you ready?
Are you ready?
Who's good if for some reason he's the only one I think.
I don't even fucking the typical,
I didn't research this,
but as far as I know,
I think legally he's the only one who can say,
let's get it on before UFC match,
which is fucking ridiculous because he didn't come up with let's get it on.
You know
what's his face?
That fucking guy with the beard who got shot by his dad used to wear the red
hat.
Marvin Gaye.
Marvin Gaye wrote a song,
let's get it on Ben in his seventies evidently he was singing to some fucking 14
year old girl.
16 son,
make him a freak.
16 in the studio trying to convince her to fuck him,
you know,
so I'm able to get up to a whole nother can of worms.
The whole r Kelly thing that uh,
I dunno,
it was acceptable back then or was it,
was there a double standard?
Wait a second.
I'm going to say Rupert Murdoch wasn't Rupert Murdoch.
Who Know what the fuck was that name?
Who's that fucking guy he was,
he was from France.
Any.
He drugged up the 14 year old and a Jack Nicholson's hot tub,
Roman Polanski.
It's funny how he got in trouble for that shit.
He had to literally leave the country.
Marvin Gaye is really singing a song about how he wants to fuck a 16 year old
and nothing ever happened to him till his dad shot him.
But I think,
I don't think that that was related.
Um,
so anyway,
I want to fucking 16 year old.
Ooh,
let's get it on sugar.
That's what he was giving her.
That's how young she was.
And you couldn't even bribe him with money.
She didn't know what it was.
He was giving them those little fucking little Halloween candies.
Oh,
did I carve a pumpkin this year?
I tried.
I took a fucking picture of it.
I called the,
I called this awesome pumpkin.
One of them suck,
but the other one,
the ACDC one,
and for the life of me,
I cannot upload it onto my fucking myspace page.
A good friend of mine heard my problem on my last podcast.
She showed me how to do it on my phone.
I was able to email the picture to myself.
I was able to save that picture in my fucking eye photo
thing,
whatever the fuck that is.
And then I went to upload it on my space and then they're like,
oh,
we have a,
we have an error.
There's an error.
I hate it.
My space,
how they go,
sorry.
There was an unexpected error.
It's like,
you know what Tom,
there's nothing unexpected about it at this point.
Okay.
If it went through,
that would have been unexpected.
All right.
I've got a little look at it.
A little fucking up,
piss and vinegar in me this week.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I do this podcast once a week here.
Um,
I do it on a billboard.com and simultaneously simultaneously here on my myspace
page and you can download these on,
uh,
was it iTunes and a,
yeah,
I do one of these every single week.
People ask me questions.
I answered the questions to the best of my ability.
And other than that,
I rant about shit and like I'm doing right now.
And,
uh,
before we get started on the podcast,
um,
I want to congratulate the Philadelphia Phillies,
but when in the world series,
look at that,
they got this second one.
What a relief that is.
I know the feeling right now.
No one can talk shit to you and no one can say shit to you for a long time.
You know,
you realize how long you have to suck now in baseball for anybody to give you
shit,
you know.
And had you fucking done that a couple of years ago,
I would've been in trouble in Camden because there there's nothing I would have,
I could have said about you
actually.
I,
I could have,
I still could've come up with something,
but I don't want to get into that.
I'm trying to mend fences.
Um,
yeah,
the silly fucking wanting,
you know,
Pete the God Damn Double Race and look at myself,
I talked myself into a corner because I have nothing mean to say about that
other than congratulations and the second year nice,
all comedy stops.
Um,
anyways.
You know what?
Let me,
let me see what,
let's,
let's hype what I Have Co.
What's hype,
what I have coming up this week.
Um,
I have,
uh,
I have to open a fucking window to know what the hell I have coming up.
Oh,
I know where I'm going to be.
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
the Improv in DC.
And let me tell you something.
Boys and girls tickets are going fast.
Um,
I get unbelievable support in DC and uh,
the fuck is wrong with my website.
Don't start this.
Oh,
there it is.
I clicked on the wrong page.
No,
I get unbelievable,
uh,
support in DC.
Um,
last time I went there,
all show sold out before even got there.
I didn't have to get up and do fucking radio,
but I still did it.
I still,
Oh,
look who's Collin and it's showed a Rosa Jody Rosa.
I'm in the middle of doing my podcast.
Let me call you right back.
I'll be done in about 20 minutes.
All right,
sweetie.
Um,
Joe Rosa,
my cohost on uninformed,
we're gonna be doing it this Friday and our in studio guest is going to be a,
actually,
he's calling is going to be Joe Perry from Aerosmith.
So we're really excited and I'll let you guys know when it's going to air
because we,
uh,
we prerecorded.
But getting back on topic this week,
I'm going to be at the Improv in Washington DC.
Last I heard there was about 150 tickets left and a,
so if you want to go,
uh,
go to,
what does it improv.com I know I got to write down on my myspace page.
You can click on it or if you're on my,
uh,
my webpage,
if you just click on upcoming appearances,
there'll be a link right there.
I'm going to be there November 6th,
November 7th,
November 8th.
And uh,
it's part of the uninformed comedy tour hyping my radio show with Joe to Rosa
who just called in.
Isn't that ironic?
Isn't it ironic?
I don't know.
I don't even know what irony means anymore.
I don't even know what fucking,
you know,
was that serendipity?
You know,
who ruined irony would the fucking hipsters,
you know,
everything became ironic.
I'm wearing an ACD,
she shirt,
but I'm wearing it ironically.
How do you do that?
How do you wear something?
Ironically,
you are wearing it.
You fuck something ironic about it.
It's covering your awful unworked out torso.
I thought irony was,
I think I've discussed this before in podcasts.
You know what we did?
And people sent me definitions and I still don't understand it.
I thought irony was when the,
the fucking fire chief's house burns to the ground.
Isn't that ironic?
Don't you think?
Right.
And then you walk around with Alannis Morissette you don't want her career went
off the rails is when she did that fucking video naked and she had her long,
uh,
fucking likes.
You just crawl out of that.
Well,
like that chick from the ring when she had that hair hanging down over a titties
and I don't,
I don't know what it was.
It was like,
she had a very pancake
shaped cheat.
She looked like a gingerbread man with long hair.
And tidies
as what it was.
What you want with a woman.
You want the curves,
right?
That little hourglass thing going on,
you know not to give women a bad fucking body image.
Women do so much shit to just fuck with their own heads.
If you ever do you ever talk to a girl and there'll be like,
you're like,
hey,
why don't you get that?
That'll look cool.
I can't wear that.
Why can't you wear that cause cause I'm a spoon.
You're a what?
I'm a spoon.
The fuck is a spoon now.
That's my body shape.
I'm a spoon.
Well why did you just say that?
Like that was a common term sweetheart.
And you find out that they actually go to these,
these fucking people and they tell them like what their body shape is.
And I guess his spooned means you don't have much in a way of of chest,
but you have a booty.
So that means you're a spoon.
You know,
if you look to hold the spoon sideways evidentaly that looks like a chick with
an ass.
Which I don't think it does.
Cause personally I am an ass man and I've never had the desire to fuck a spoon,
even though he eats cereal every morning for breakfast.
Okay,
and you just tidies.
What is that on the capital t?
I can't wear a hoop skirt.
I'm a capital.
I mean,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
They just come up,
you know?
I don't,
I don't know what I am.
You know?
Actually,
one time I actually looked at myself standing sideways,
completely naked in a mirror,
right?
I was in a hotel and I realize that I am shaped like the pink panther.
Pink Panther has a big head and he's,
and he's got big feet and they use his body that just goes straight,
straight down.
That's,
that's how I'm shaped.
I like to think my,
I have better shoulders than the pink panther,
but I don't know.
You know,
that's not for me to judge.
That's for the poor woman who's hooked up.
You know what?
Fuck this.
Let's get to the podcast questions.
Why am I telling you guys about looking at myself?
Make it an a fucking man.
Yo,
I'll do it with everybody.
Does it?
Um,
Eh,
the,
the elections tomorrow.
By the way,
if you're listening to this on Monday,
uh,
as of tomorrow,
um,
you know,
maybe we're going to have a new president if Bush doesn't declare martial law in
the last second being that's going to come down to Florida again and they're
going to be trying to count fucking votes.
I Dunno.
I'm really nervous that they're going to leave,
that Obama's going to win and they're going to leave him
to try and clean up this unclean appealable mess.
I don't know.
It was just too fucking depressing to think about.
I do.
Whoever wins.
Okay.
You know what the great thing about this election is if McCain winds or Obama
wins,
at the very least,
we're going to have a president again,
that can actually make a speech without you having to look away.
And I think that's good.
I think that's good.
Even though they both worked for the Rothschilds and we're on our way to one
world government,
one World Bank.
Fuck.
I was trying not to say that you guys seen that commercial out where they're
going to make it easier for us to travel between Mexico,
the Co,
the Caribbean and Canada.
If we all have enhanced driver's license,
wink link,
enhance microchip in it so they can track your whereabouts cause they're trying
to get the cherish trying to get terrorist.
What?
I'm trying to see what you're doing.
We're trying to get terrorist.
Hey man,
he ain't doing nothing wrong.
He shouldn't have fucking time with it.
People who say that should be processed,
you know,
I don't think they should be killed.
I,
you know,
I don't know what to do with them.
Should I go with the Hacky,
stick them on an island and give him some big fucking cotton candy machine.
Most of those fucking people in government can listen to your phone calls.
Well,
if you ain't doing nothing wrong,
the government can fuck you in the ass.
Well high.
If you got little boy,
you ain't got no fucking morons.
Yeah,
just keep giving away more rights.
People just keep doing that,
you know,
and I'm going to keep bitching about it as I don't join any groups to prevent it
or organize or show up at anywhere.
Alleys.
I'm that guy.
I'm that guy who sits there and goes,
hey,
you know what the problem is and then I don't do anything about it.
I'm an asshole.
All right,
question number one of the week.
Uh,
number one bill.
we need nicknames.
And who better to ask than one of the commentators from the racetrack?
The fuck does that mean love the podcast?
Just thought it would be something to talk about.
What uh,
what's the funniest nicknames for a fighter and what would you name the four
guys on our main picture?
What,
how do you think he would fair as a fighter or was a corner man also who's the
best fighter ever?
I'll answer those last three cause I don't understand the first.
I mean I'm probably fucking it up.
I mean sometimes people write sentences that make sense.
But I read so poorly that when I read them out loud I pause and weird areas and
then they don't make sense to me or the listener.
And it's one of the reasons why I was never successful when I ran for student
government.
I didn't run for student government.
Um,
I was too busy flunking every class that I had.
I was too busy doing that.
Um,
all right,
bill,
what a c,
how do you think you would fare as a fighter?
I'm into it depends cause the other person know how to fight.
Is that one of those brother to brother headlock Nogi fights?
I always did well in those.
Um,
how would I fair as a fighter?
I think,
I think I'm all right.
I think I'm on as long as the other person isn't trained.
If anybody has any sort of training or any sort of background,
I'm fucked because I don't have any training and have a huge head and that's a
big target.
In fact,
I was voted most likely to be assassinated and uh,
I think I've used that joke before.
I just love that one.
Anytime you see anyone.
The big head and the crowd.
That's what I always think like you could,
you wouldn't even need to put that guy in a convertible.
You could hit them with a slingshot from the other side of a fucking cotton
field.
Like I actually know the size of a cotton field like anybody does,
you know,
other even cotton fields anymore.
Did that go out with NAFTA?
See what we're gonna do is we're going to,
we're going to sand a cotton for you.
We have other,
you pick our cotton and then we're going to buy the shirts back from them.
Um,
anyways,
how I think I would fare as a fighter.
I think if somebody is a no background,
basically angry cycle like me,
I think I can hold my own,
although I'm getting a little advanced in age,
40 years old,
wake up with aches and pains.
Um,
I think I would fare okay as a professional fighter.
I would not make it out of the cubs scouts,
whatever that version is of being a boxer.
I have a complete inability to,
I don't know.
It's weird.
I have good hand eye coordination.
I can catch things very easily,
but I'm not fast,
which basically means you can be like,
Bill,
I'm going to,
you could tell me what fist you're going to hit me and what punched you were
going to throw an 80% of the time.
You'd still fucking hit me in the head because I,
I don't know.
By the time I,
I know what you're doing.
The only thing I have left to do is close my eyes and lift my shoulders as if
that does anything.
You know,
you know that move.
When are you going to get hit?
You ever see that guy?
You look away,
close your eyes and lift your shoulders.
That's always a good deal.
Why would you and why?
Why would,
why wouldn't you rather lift your hand up and try to fucking,
you know how boxes do and block it?
What I do is I close my eyes.
I looked the other way and I lift my shoulders.
I'm basically trying to protect my,
from my juggler up to my ear lobe,
but my jaw and my temple and all that other stuff.
That's all for you.
You can have that all day long,
baby.
I'll fucking eat it up.
All right.
Um,
how would I fair as a corner man?
Uh,
you know,
if you don't know how to fight,
how can you tell somebody how to fight and who's the best fighter ever?
All right.
That's some really speaking in general terms.
How about my favorite fighter ever?
My favorite fighter ever.
We're all,
all the middleweights from the 80s,
except for Sugar Ray Leonard.
I don't know.
He was just too cute.
I like Tommy Hearns and Marvin Hagler was my favorite.
I love Roberto Duran.
I like,
I love boxing.
Back then Alexis are Gwalia,
Aaron Pryor giving the bottle now the one that I mixed.
Um,
that's a fight.
Fans.
Um,
and who else did I like back then?
Larry Holmes.
I liked
Mike Tyson.
I love,
but he scared the shit out of me.
I like Michael Spinks.
I like Leon Spinks.
That was it.
There you go.
Those are the guys I liked.
None of that was funny.
I'm really boring the shit on myself.
Okay,
let's ratchet up the funny here.
Number two,
Bill,
you ever come into,
you ever going to come to Dallas?
How about this?
Are you ever going to come to the show?
When I go to Dallas,
they go to Dallas every year.
That's one of my pet fucking peeves is when people send me fucking emails.
Right.
Like I just got back from Austin and I got a letter this email this week.
Do you ever call me to Texas?
You know,
just look at my website.
I got all the dates.
Okay.
And speaking of which,
I got a slew of dates,
which means a lot.
I have a plethora of dates.
I have a fuck load of dates coming up.
Then I'm gonna be putting up on my website [inaudible] dot com and um,
yeah,
I'm going to have a whole bunch of dates for a January.
Um,
January,
2009,
right?
Two December,
2009 or as other people like to say 2009.
And um,
Houston,
Texas is going to be there for all you fuckers who keep asking me to come to
even though every time I go there,
11 people show up.
And you guys with your empty promises.
Do you come out?
I,
I'm good to bring 20 and I up and there's 18 fucking people and I'm standing up
there,
you know,
feeling like I'm giving away ruble.
I'm seriously,
I got a whole bunch of dates coming up and I'm going to be posting them and I'm
have a trip to Europe and Australia in the works in the work.
So England,
Sweden,
Norway.
All right.
Put on your fucking comedy hats cause I'm coming your way and uh,
also coming to Australia I believe next year.
Anyways,
here we go.
Continuing on the next question.
What do we got here?
Uh,
but the,
okay,
bill,
I've subscribed to your podcast on iTunes since the beginning and you are now
over a day of talking straight.
You know what I noticed that I've done over 24 hours of podcast minutes anyways.
How is the podcast affected you since you started it?
Um,
see I just did that.
The sentence was how has the podcast affect affected you since you started it?
And I read it this way,
how has the podcast affected you since you started it?
That's exactly how I hit this weird pause.
And then I said,
oh my God,
there's another word.
Because I was already thinking of the answer.
How has it affected me?
Um,
I don't know.
I think my ability to talk to myself on a phone for 40 minutes has really
improved.
Um,
it's helped me with my radio show to the point that I really feel like I could
do an hour of radio by myself,
just as long as I wasn't in a panic state of,
oh my God,
there's nobody else in here.
What am I going to talk about half?
As long as I didn't go to that place and I just had a couple of subjects I can
sort of subject surf through my huge head and uh,
you know,
I think it's affected me that way.
I'm know maybe I can improv a little bit better or maybe the standup has helped
me,
I don't know.
But,
uh,
I've had a lot of people come up to me and shows and tell me that they now that
it's on Itunes,
that,
you know,
they listen to it at work or they have like a designated time when they listened
to it and they've gone back.
And I had one person tell me one night they sat there and they listened to like
all the way back to the summertime,
stayed up for like six hours listening to my podcast,
which was really flattering because I think I'm boring as shit a lot of the
times.
Look at me searching for a compliment now you are,
you're not boring,
blah,
blah blah.
Um,
no,
I think it's been a great thing and it's something that,
uh,
last week when I did the very special one and I had Joe to Rosa,
I think I'm going to be doing more of those.
I enjoy,
uh,
I dunno,
I like working with other people in problem with them fucking around.
And if I could figure out a way to block my,
uh,
my podcasts,
maybe I could do one where I could actually call someone a regular listener
or have somebody call in.
I don't know how the fuck I could do,
but then it would just be awkward.
I always feel like that those things never live up to the hype.
Someone's like all excited and then it just turns into that member that Chris
Farley character they used to do,
you know,
the really bad interviewer or he would just be like interviewing Paul Mccartney
and be like,
I remember,
I remember the time when it's time you guys,
you guys did the sergeant pepper pepper album and then Paul Mccartney,
he's like,
yeah,
I do remember that night.
And he just feel like that was awesome.
Like I worry that it will just become that like a fucking staring contest.
I,
you know,
I actually worry,
I worry that would actually,
the podcast would be as bad as the awful recreation of that Chris Farley bid.
Did you like my really bad English accent than I did in there?
It was so bad that I literally had to throw in mate at the end of it so you'd
know that Oh,
he is doing an English accent.
I thought he just raised his voice and octaves.
Okay,
let's,
let's plow ahead.
Okay.
Well,
um,
you should start writing a book on your stadium travels.
You can give yourself the excuse that you're doing it to make money.
Oh yeah.
Rather than being a loser and get on that new sports soup show,
you would be excellent on it.
Um,
yeah.
For those of you who weren't listening in the past couple of weeks,
I'm actually,
um,
I'm not going home for the holidays.
Thanksgiving,
I'm not going home on Christmas and I'm not working new years.
I'm tapping out fuck the masses.
I'm taking a break and a,
instead,
I'm actually going to Calgary,
Edmonton and Vancouver with a buddy of mine and we're going to watch,
I know I'm going to go,
go fucking go to some hockey games and get absolutely shit faced with their
extra alcohol beer.
And,
um,
that's so I'm going to do and people have called me a fag,
you know,
dual.
How are you doing that?
Where are you,
you know,
that kind of stuff.
But I don't care.
I like doing it,
but I know I'm also a psycho when it comes to,
I have like OCD like big time.
Like I've so gotten into hockey that I just ordered the NHL package and I am
literally watching like three hockey games a night.
Like I watched what the one hockey game that interests me and then I taped to
others and then I watch them like literally like a fucking assistant coach.
And uh,
I dunno,
I've been thinking about doing like a book on it,
but you know something,
the whole reason why I became a comedian is cause I don't want to have a job.
I don't want to do work.
I just want to do this.
Like I don't prepare for these podcasts.
I just laid down on the bed and I run my fucking mouth for 45.
That's how I like doing shit.
I don't like rehearsing.
I don't like organizing shit.
I don't like coming up with business models and you know,
I don't want to write a book about my stadium Shit.
I just want to,
I just want to go to them and get drunk and talk to some,
the oldest guy I can find with the oldest looking Jersey of the team and to ask
them,
what was it like years ago when you went to the fucking stadium?
You know,
like I love going to Pittsburgh and talking to fucking,
you know,
the guy driving me from the airport.
I look at him like,
okay,
that guy's like in his fifties so that means 30 years ago he was in his
twenties.
If I was in my twenties in Pittsburgh,
I would've gone to three rivers stadium and I would've watched Franco,
Terri,
Lynn Swann and all those guys.
And I asked him,
do you ever go over there?
And He'd be law.
Yeah,
it was fucking awesome.
Then you hear these great stories.
I was at that game,
Fred Biletnikoff from the Raiders and yeah,
you can just,
I know I whatever.
I'm a fucking nerd.
Okay,
so next question.
I noticed the trend.
You have a loving to rag on either crazy or stupid people.
Um,
hold,
Geez,
aren't you perceptive?
Well,
I noticed you're kind of angry.
I'm going to go on a limb here because of this.
I was wondering how you feel about Sarah Pailin given the fact that she is both
of these things crazy and stupid.
I don't think she's stupid.
I just think she's not ready.
You know,
I think she's really green.
You know what I mean?
She's more comes off as somebody David Letterman would,
would talk to in a bit,
you know,
because they make their own jam and they put it in a jar.
I'll tell you.
Well,
you know what,
I really don't like.
I don't like how Obama and John Mccain and all these fucking guys are like on
ESPN and they're going on Saturday night live.
And I think it really trivializes what they're doing.
You know what I mean?
I think,
uh,
that they should be on shows like meet the press and they should be doing
debates.
And I think that,
you know,
you're not supposed to combine church and state.
I don't think you should combine political figures and sketch comedy shows that
make fun of them.
And then they go on there and they're all in on the joke,
like,
yeah,
I'm a fucking idiot.
That doesn't really make me confidence.
And either Mccain,
Obama and,
uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I gotta I gotta tell you something though.
I really want to get a John Mccain shirt and just wear it around La just because
I love annoying people,
you know?
And uh,
you know,
I just think that would be funny just to have people that can't fucking get this
John Mccain.
Shit,
shut up.
Why don't you just shut up?
Why don't you stop?
I just want to give me people's noses.
I can get to wrinkle,
um,
about tie right now.
I'm gonna tell you I'm,
I'm voting for Ron Paul and vote for Ron Paul and I don't give a fuck.
I vote for guys from here on out who questioned the Federal Reserve.
And other than that,
if you don't do that,
then you're,
you're just another company guy and I have no use for you.
All right?
Underrated.
Overrated.
Um,
somebody said,
oh look at this underrated Doug Davidoff and uh,
I believe that he's in my top 80 friends there on the page.
Hilarious comedian.
This Preston says he's underrated.
He's a great and really under,
under the radar comedian.
So checkout Doug Davidoff everybody.
Um,
and this is a,
I love this one.
Underrated the cable guy.
It was a good movie.
You know what?
I love that movie.
I think there's just one too many music montage us.
You know what I mean?
But I have to admit that I downloaded that song,
uh,
that hey man,
nice shot when a Jim Carrey goes out,
you know,
dressed old school with the short shorts and the,
does he have a headband?
Don't.
Anyways,
he puts in the mouth guard and he's playing basketball,
but there's just one too many of those.
But I loved that movie.
I thought it was really dark and really creepy,
which is probably why it didn't do as well.
It didn't perform as well at the box office as they want it to because people
like to go to the movie theater and forget their problems.
Um,
overrated.
Splenda,
it's disgusting.
What the fuck is Splenda again?
Is that,
that stuff that makes Doritos not make you fat but your ass leaks?
Is that what that is?
Um,
overrated.
Pink Floyd prison tee shirts.
Uh,
it's a great one.
I Love Pink Floyd,
but there,
there are way too many dumb teenagers wearing that shirt that don't know what
the hell it is.
And I have to ask you a question person who wrote that in.
When you say they don't know what that is,
do you mean they don't really know what pink Floyd is or they don't know what
the prison is?
Cause I got to tell you,
I've owned dark side of the moon forever and I don't know what the prison means
either.
I don't even know what a prison is other than a triangle that makes you go,
wow man,
look at the colors and freaking out.
Um,
I do want to tell you this.
I,
uh,
let me,
let me check the time of the podcast here.
28 minutes.
That's decent.
We're going to wrap this up at about 30.
That's a good one.
Um,
yeah,
one of the best musical experiences I ever had was I bought pink Floyd.
God dammit,
the phone's ringing.
And who's this?
Greg Fitzsimmons.
Hang on a second.
Greg.
Fitzsimmons.
Hello Gregory.
Oh wait a minute.
He pocket dialed me.
Let me listen to see if he's talking about me.
Uh,
no,
he's not.
No such luck.
You know what?
And now he's,
he's going to call me back like 19 times,
cause I'm the last guy he calls and every time he reaches over,
just scratch his right ball.
His left ball is going to hit send on his cell phone and he's going to call me.
Anyways,
getting back to the,
uh,
pink Floyd,
a musical experience,
I bought that,
uh,
I believe on cassette tape
and I had headphones just like in dazed and confused and I listened to that in
the dark for the first time.
That is for all you youngsters out there who are not jaded and as long as you
haven't watched his face as a death or any of that type of shit is still
relatively innocent.
Like I was back then pre internet days,
even though the Internet existed,
but it only existed for fucking nerds.
I listened to that album in the dark and that album scared the living shit out
of me.
It's incredible music.
But that shit with people running down the halls and heartbeats and all that
type of crap,
that really,
really scared the hell out of me.
And it's a fucking masterpiece.
So if you get a chance,
get some headphones,
if you can buy it on vinyl,
off of Ebay,
you know you don't even need drugs.
That's how good pink Floyd is.
And a,
and then you go,
all right,
the original pink,
pink Floyd and I got a question,
would you guys want anybody out there?
Would you like to hook up with that girl pink?
There's something really hot about her.
But then she's also kind of built like a full back
like you know,
like she,
I dunno
not to use the classic,
I think she rip your Dick off man.
Uh,
anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Half Hour.
They had gone furniture and back a little bit.
These podcasts will becoming a little too long,
kind of like jam band shit.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm going to be at the Improv in Washington DC this week.
Uh,
the eighth ninth,
I can't even fucking read it,
cause know the sixth,
seventh and 8th of November.
And uh,
the following week I'm going to be uninformed tour with Joe to Rosa.
Once again,
we'll be at Nashville's Nashville common disease in Nashville to,
I can't read November 13th,
14th and 15th.
Um,
just click on the link if you're on the mindspace page,
if you're on bill bird.com just click on upcoming appearances and then click the
link.
Please keep the questions coming.
Please keep underrated,
overrated coming.
And please answer my question.
What a a prism is and what the fuck it is,
whatever that triangle is,
I don't fucking know.
All right.
Now I've got a headache and I've lost total momentum on this podcast.
It's not funny anymore and it needs to fucking stop.
All right,
everybody go out and vote tomorrow.
Go with your gut and a,
actually try to read the questions.
That's what I'm going to do today.
You know those stupid little science people have voted no on a man and then you
keep a running tally.
Wow.
Everybody keeps saying vote nos.
And then you vote no.
And you read that little paragraph.
Can anybody explain to me why those,
when they have those questions,
it's never clear.
It's always no means yes and yes means no.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
why?
Why can't they just fucking just say what the questions mean?
Why can't we just live in a perfect world?
Hey Bill,
why don't you just shut the fuck up and in the podcast?
All right.
That's what I'm gonna do.
I'll talk to you guys next Monday.
Um,
that is God bless all you.
And uh,
they,
the time.
Next week we'll have a new president.
Isn't that exciting?
Someone who can make a speech.
All right.
Who are you voting for?
The white guy or the off white guy.
Thank you.
I'll be at the fucking DC Improv this week.
Please come out to the show.
All right,
mother fuckers.
Have a good week.
So,
so
[inaudible] [inaudible]
uh.